i built a really cool website to see it  you can visit http localhost 3000. the  only problem is that url only works on  my local computer i could go out and buy  a domain name web server and ssl  certificate then figure out how to get  my code to work on the internet but what  if i just want to share a quick preview  of this website with a friend or maybe  test a service worker over https that's  where tunnels come in you can use free  tools like ngrok or cloudflare tunnels  to set up a secure but temporary  connection between your localhost and  the internet just download the  cloudflare tunnel cli tool run the  tunnel command and point it to the local  host port you want to serve and it will  spit out a url where now anybody can  view your localhost on the internet